this is going to be a bit tricky you
might need your friend to help you here
to try and flip back and forth because
read the question with me and pretty
quickly you realize you need some more
information than what the question just
give you let's read
it's a secret 17 living at home and
unemployed I'll talk about what that
word means in a second because it's a
bit it's not as obvious as you might
sound she earns two hundred five dollars
per fortnight and is entitled to youth
allowance calculate the allowance Ingrid
will receive okay pause for a moment
let's um let's get our pin and pin okay
and as usual it's right down the
essential details before we get into
this is question seems okay so you have
a look right now it tells us her age and
it tells us something about her
circumstances that's because as I
mentioned before that's all allowances
are bad you've got to kind of know these
right so Ingrid is that age that's
important would look at her age in a
second she's living at home and she's
unemployed now even though most people
would say Oh unemployed it means you
don't have a job okay there's something
else in the question that tells you
actually that's not what they meant at
all what tells you that she's not
unemployed in that sense yeah she's
earning money a fair bit of it as well
right so when they say unemployed in
this context right this is actually
referring to she's not studying that's
really what's happening so there are
different rules that apply for people to
study and people who don't
so it means employed in study okay so
linear homes she's not studying and then
she's got this income five
and then it says as if as if that's
enough okay
work out the youth allowance for me okay
now have you written down these
essential facts I'm pretty sure that's
all of them
okay what we now need to do is you need
to sit back a little bit so in your
textbook they help this huge massive
table okay if you go to let me just
check for you it's either one or two
pages back I'll show you what it looks
like so you know you're on the right one
here we go okay and there's two were
interested in the first ones on page 17
so it looks like this can you see that
one pitch something it's at the bottom
of the page and it's this smaller
looking table and it says then handing
out circumstance and formatting papers
you see that one yeah okay now just look
at that one with me and see how it
relates to Ingrid here right it's just
talking about the life circumstances
that's her age where she's living and um
when we talk about the employment in a
second right so which one of these rows
does Ingrid fall under under 18 Oh in
fact luckily for us it's just the first
one yeah it's just the first one so
we're assuming she can go with their
children based on information she's been
we've been given so therefore what I'm
going to say is the full payment would
equal and everything on a fortnightly
basis because usually salaries and stuff
like that hour of fortnightly basis the
full payment would be children three
dollars and forty cents so that's what I
get from the first table okay I've got
it that down now move over the page and
have a look at the next considerably
larger more intimidating table okay so
this is the one which at the top it says
personal income test for youth allowance
now on yeah now this is what this is
talking about right then I'm just gonna
hand her back I'm out of money straight
off because she's earning an extra
amount of money but in addition right
so therefore have a look at this table
again which one is she again she's that
first row right and then in the second
column you can see you're either a
student or you're unemployed you see
that's how I can tell unemployed
actually doesn't mean no dog it means
you're not staying okay so she is she is
our employee right so I'm looking at the
second row in that on the second line of
writing in the first block there right
so have a look at those two columns on
the right hand side down see this these
two one two one that's his full mast and
one that says pot did you see that one
yeah okay now do you see it talks about
how much income she makes and then asked
well how much does that compare to what
she's actually so she's having two
hundred five dollars per fortnight right
so reading that last pair of columns
there it says she can earn up to one
hundred and forty three dollars and
still get this full amount she could
have owned up to that amount okay and
still get that is she earning up to that
amount she's just gone over hasn't she
so there's like a threshold there and
she's passed over now here's an
important thing you might want to jot
this down and I'll explain it in a
second remember I said most sub
allowances a subject to an income test
right what happens is as you pass over
that threshold right the allowance will
decrease in proportion to how much
you're earning over the threshold right
it doesn't just like magically cut off
all of a sudden okay so he allows that
you get life is two to three dollars and
forty cents the government will take
slices of that in proportion
- how much you're over the threshold and
we said that threshold was $143 right